pgl csgo major Kakao is right around the
corner and to hype you guys up we
decided to put together a list of the
top ten best place for majors throughout
the years for this list we're focusing
on plays not moment that's in our other
video coming in at number 10 its
Freiburg crazy spray transfer some
behind the ball mill town but ours got
him trapped in the corneal drop the
finished player is gone announcer to V
to retake for an IP e to hold on to this
to not lose the Grand Finals pronate and
creams they just need to two killed here
and they will win it for the second time
product with one private and planet
continues 1513 oh my god I'm at a loss
for words right now grabbing the ninth
spot it's wags unbelievable one before
against n IP strike to force the agenda
they try to keep an IP off guard they're
like you know what they're not expecting
that that they're expecting us to be
passive and that may have been the
better decision because it's all gone
wrong for complexity and they have that
much money in the first place yeah well
I was a very good Gama though if exist
wasn't ready for that he would have been
taken down straightaway but and I feel
we're ready to just
oh it's Jimbo bozo about swag he's got
two kills answer what kill and he plays
a very low health let's see this would
be this would be magic
now again I'm just I'm just waiting for
you I'm just waiting for swag rain very
huge and Bennett won't freeze
he's a kind of favor when I stick with
his weapon and these are going to look
for headshot if he does this you have to
say sacre bleu here we go our French
pushes in get on Tex Rex
Kenny follow up he's worked that helped
really far but he's done a lot of damage
both players have no health one health
point of America 11 on the next here we
go so I get to surprise rip it something
addictive my wife delivered can you
believe it that it's a facial from sweat
and complexity will pick up the round
and that is unbelievable our 8th spot
goes to je tiens 1 be 5/8 clutch vs.
team envyus
be already pushing forward to trying to
find them decimals in his sights manages
only one vide I'm looking at correct
direction but it's a one versus four AWP
push out good shot JDS looks for another
he's got the count of one versus two
over a commitment and perhaps a little
bit jealous to try it early end this oh
I'm getting it taken down to the boss
what it bathroom JDM the a squat should
we stay alive coming in seventh is
olofmeister spec 9 8 during ESL one
Katowice 8 2015 20 in time it's going to
be Guardian to give prim and soos look
at that running and gunning
takes down JW and all of my foot tech 9
and armor it's really really good
combination but unless they fight in one
of the time oh my god they will pronax
helping out with that kill and Guardian
going down it's not a triple kill for
all of my stuff plenty of help to do
this as well soos is very low C's
although oh my god he gets another kill
in now trots running out 7 seconds all
of much looking for the Gil 5 seconds it
goes for exit and it's going to be the
round done our 6th spot goes to rain and
his monstrous 1v5 one of the cleanest 25
he's ever seen taking down 3 players now
it's just rain left alive he's going to
find a quick kill on to happy but he's
got kioshima to contend with what a frag
they're coming in from rain he's gonna
be pushing it to the bomb side the clock
is on his back he's got the smoke for
cover
make the approach to the bomb site it
does have some climbers way-o try to get
the frag on to the flanking player it
game sense confidence man is unreal
there's still two more players to find
though raid he's going to get another
one
fpk goes out he's created a 101 he's got
so much time to use as well he's going
to make his way back back towards the
middle position I'm gonna try to trick
his opponent right now apex oh oh my
goodness
greatest me rain is an absolute monster
killing the fifth spot is ni pees get
right for his last second clutch against
TSM J does go down Cajun three bullets
left and he's finally going to trying to
reload him it's to be 300 and there it
is
yeah right Last Man Standing device that
draws speed he's goes he's gonna go down
if that have been the old seat said it
would have no issue at all get right try
to walk now one v two running up here P
250 out jumping and shooting he gets one
more kill looking for these got any
money down time is up oh my god they're
already gonna be kidding me love killing
one second left coming in fourth is he
goes one before to save the round at MLG
Columbus again as we seen so many times
before it's out the heater but against
four is it really possible we do have a
few players quite tagged up here from
luminosity so he co definitely not going
down without a fight
oh well there's the first box right here
go get the double there's still two
players left they got no help on them 13
and 3 hiko goofing around the site now
there's still time it's all my goodness
how did he do it again
grabbing the third spot is simple 1v2
falling off against fnatic at ESL
cologne 2016 and the desperate play into
become dinner smokes double smoking in
the same place I suppose it's jumping
hardly to the platform therefore I use
various what is that you guys because
they're cool that's not allowed
is it so SPL this is a major it's import
I don't know man if he comes in with
scope because III mean after you have
one file on his mouth that he have one
bottle coming in second if snacks is
sneaky peeky play during the grand final
at EMF one Katowice lettuce bro touch
that
but stick is walking around he waited he
waited he waited and then he finished up
this joke our number one spot goes to
cold xerath iconic jumping off against
team liquid at MLG 2016 gotta hit these
shots we taught formulas in this spot
before the same spot that put with much
more utility to work with
here it comes once again the first base
is a trainees going to hit the ground
there is hole uh-oh
big double for cold what is we going on
right now how do we do this called
escape velocity with your way of
thinking all scenes there on the B
apartment they needed a huge way but I
was something I'm never going to see
ever again ridiculous from that's the
most ridiculous thing I've ever seen it
was a noscope as well right those were
our picks for the top 10 plays from
major throughout the years do you feel
like we missed something
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button